People have been
requesting fireworks videos
for quite a long time.
We thought we'd add something extra
into fireworks videos.
We've got a big old rocket here.
We've filmed fireworks in the past,
and it's not right very exciting
because it's very smoky
and you can't really see what's going on.
So we figured
plop one in a little bucket of paint
and let's have a fireworky
painty explosion.
It should be good.
It won't be fun to clean up though.
It won't be fun.
Thankfully, I don't live here.
So we'll see what happens
at the end of the shoot.
It's the best.
Oh god, I knew that would happen.
Shot out didn't it?
Yeah, it did, yeah.
Shot out.
Yeah.
Made a bit of a mess of the paint.
So let's pour this bad
stuff into a paint tin.
Well, oh, it looks like bloody
Stinks!
Why does it smell so bad?
Don't know!
I usually like the smell of paint,
but that is howlin'.
Oh! Is it a dud?
Oh my god!
The paint looked quite solid
as it was moving around didn't it?
Yeah.
And then the flame is
just coming out of it
and I like the bit where the
pressure of the smoke inside
just sort of busted out
the side of the paint.
Yeah!
It was like a volcano of paint
just full of smoke.
Alright. Let's let's do,
let's do globby red and blue I think.
Yeah.
Get rid of that. I'll get blue.
Sweet.Three two one go.
This is going to be interesting.
That was cool. Oh my God landed behind me.
Look at that. It's like, ah,
that's odd, that is
It's like gunpowder and
Look we made some green.
Alright.Banger.
Well I guess when in doubt you
put the fire fireworks away
and use a banger
That was super effective.
Look at this. It's splashed
the paint into the bath.
It's got paint in the section bath.
So we've got a big mess now
because it's blown the side
completely out of our pot
that we were using. Oh God,
it doesn't look nice though. Doesn't it?
I think I'm going to decorate my room.
Like paint it white and then
do this in the middle of the
room.
Analyze the splash damage.
New species of plant.
I think I prefer actually
it's already good.
Like pretty day just going up there.
It's up there in the tree.
That's a good aftermath.
Alright, what's happening now, Daniel.
We're going for a multi-fireworks
extravaganza. We've got some small ones,
some big ones, some
medium ones. Going to try
lighting as many as I can.
Alright. Oh God.
Whoops! Let's see. I don't think it did
anything to the paint. It just shot
Yeah the paint was just like yeah what
Well that was good fun.
It's raining again,
so we're going to have to put the kit away
but there's paint everywhere
and I'm not looking forward to
cleaning it up.
We should probably revisit this one.
Maybe with bigger tins of
paint and bigger explosives.
The banger was definitely
the best one. Wasn't it?
I agree. Several bangers would be good.
So
Let's head out.